hi I'm like Maybin let's say Geography
Bee winner from Bismarck North Dakota
and I'm going to tell you a little bit
the state capitol building is the
tallest building in North Dakota and an
interesting fact about it is that nobody
in the entire state can be tolerant you
can if you were to visit my state one of
the prices you've probably come is the
North Dakota Heritage Center it's right
across the street in the capital and it
has a lot of stuff about the history and
famous people I'm not to cut us a big
producer olive oil but we're also a
leader in renewable energy right now and
this many wind farms we have in the
state I think the being green is really
important to conservation and protecting
our environment another cool place
around where I live is boredom at
Lincoln and behind me is general
Custer's house it's where he stayed
before he went to the Battle of Little
Bighorn in Montana this is the honest
land in the village at Fort Lincoln it's
where the Mandan Indians used to live
and Lewis and Clark came through here
over 200 years ago and if I was a famous
explorer I'd be lewis and clark because
they were the first people to explore
the western part of what's now the
united states this is one of the
blockhouses support Abraham Lincoln and
we're right across the river from
Bismarck right now and I'm gonna close
out the video with one more interesting
fact about North Dakota that is the
geographical center of north america
you